one on that one overnight that's it
yeah i think so
b
i believe we're live now are we
are we live now martin yes i believe so
chair
brilliant okay welcome everyone to the
meeting of the
northeast irish district council's
cabinet on the
uh 29th of october we've got a small
uh agenda today with the with the sing a
single paper
um so it should be a fairly quick
meeting but welcome
and hope you find it interesting um
firstly are there any apologies for
absence
uh none have been received chair
non-receiving i think we i can see we're
all here thank you
thank you any uh declarations of
interest
again not being received here okay thank
you
so then we move to the local plan
examination report
uh main modification to the public
consultation
over to you counselor cupid thank you
um thanks chair um i don't propose to go
through the report in
any detail uh any questions but i think
there are just a few
updates that i've been discussing with
officers today which were mentioned in
the report
but i'm happy to relay for everybody's
benefit
um i guess the first key point to note
just for anybody watching
is that this paper is to approve
the load plan main modifications go into
consultation
it's not uh the cabinet sort of
endorsing or commenting on the actual
modifications which have been set by the
inspector
so it's literally just uh facilitating
the consultation
um in terms of the updates at um i think
it's
paragraph 1.11 there was a note
on the final findings of the
sustainability
appraisal and habitats regulation
assessment
just to confirm the cabinet that the
final report has been received
and there has um been noted that there's
no
adverse impacts or no changes needed as
a result of those
um in addition at i think it's the
consultation arrangements paragraph 1.14
uh just to note that we've been told by
uh derbish county council libraries that
we're not able
to place paper copies um of the
consultation documents
into the libraries due to their
coronavirus regulations
but that was anticipated that that would
be quite a strong likelihood
so again there will be paper copies
available in the council building in
mill lane and also paper copies
available to be sent out to anybody who
needs them
um but just to note that they are all
available online
and obviously that's more climate change
friendly
method given the stack of papers
involved here
final points are just that um i think he
was at paragraph 3.1
um it was noted that we had the local
plan steering group
last week and that i'd feed back any
comments
i don't think there's anything major to
feedback other than that the
local plant steering group uh
unanimously endorsed
uh proceeding to consultation and the
consultation arrangements
um so yeah i think i think that's
everything pending any questions
and just to know obviously we are aware
of rising crane virus cases
in northeast derbyshire and should
anything change
we will uh we do have that power in the
recommendations to be able to extend the
consultation if necessary
or if there are any emergencies um yeah
any questions
okay thank you councillor cupid any
questions there
uh on the basis of that of that report
no okay well i'm happy to second
obviously
uh it's pleasing to see that we've
extended the the
uh sort of uh minimum
uh amount of consultation required we're
extending it from six weeks to seven and
a half
and obviously i'm assuming we will um
we will uh take kindly on people in
terms of the christmas post
um and any any any late late comments
received try
our hardest to take them into account
we're obviously hampered by
by coronavirus in terms of this
consultation but we know that there is a
lot of strong feeling
in many of our communities and we
obviously want to actively
encourage residents to take part in this
consultation and really
tell the inspector what they think about
the final
recommendations i know that um many of
us as local councillors will be doing a
lot in our own different wards
um to try and encourage consultation
responses
um and really really um get the views of
our communities across to the inspector
which is
vitally important uh in this in this
final consultation
so i'm i'm happy to second the uh the
recommendations that we moved to
consultation um all those in favor
okay thank you that's unanimously
carried and then we move
to uh urgent items i believe
uh i have none
so on that basis thank you very much for
your attendance and i'll
declare the meeting closed
you